Bonsoir ! Ah mais là ça marche pas, parce qu'à la base ils sont 2...
1... 2... 3... Bonsoir !
Mais du coup, ils voient là qu'il n'y a pas la deuxième personne... Ca fait pasMcFly et Carlito...
Du coup, c'est du prank raté.
C'est pas grave. Bonsoir et bonjour parce que... En plus ça marche pas du tout ton idée, la vidéo elle sort à 6h du matin !
Donc, en fait, pourquoi on dirait bonsoir ?
(Voix off) C'était pour la blague.
C'est pas faux. Bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau casse tête ! Ca fait un peu le télé-achat des casse-têtes...
La semaine dernière avec Loïc, on vous a fait...
un petit cadenas pour libérer une pièce, là, je reviens un peu aux fondamentaux du début de l'été, à savoir...
essayer d'ouvrir une boîte. Et si elle s'appelle la boîte d'Einstein,
autrement appelé en anglais la "Spider Box", ce qui n'a clairement rien à voir... Je ne sais pas pourquoi en français ils l'ont appelée la boîte d'Einstein...
Moi je trouvais ça sympa...
Parce que Einstein n'est jamais loin dans mes vidéos. Par contre la "Spider Box" ça me paraissait un peu...
probable, puisqu'on a l'araignée qui est ici.
La boîte, c'est toujours du matos artisanal, comme d'habitude, et finement fait, et on va commencer par voir, comme d'habitude sur les boîtes...
quels sont les éléments que je peux bouger, qu'est-ce qui est déplaçable ou pas.
Il faut quand même savoir que cette petite boîte, qui n'a l'air de rien, est d'un niveau de difficulté...
extrême.
Donc j'espère réussir à l'ouvrir en une vidéo. Alors la première étape, c'est ça, quand il y a du métal, c'est qu'il y a peut-être des aimants...
Et s'il y a un aimant, du coup, il faut trouver l'aimant pour pouvoir enlever ça. Comme dans la Pandora Box, je sais pas si vous vous souvenez,
la Pandora Box, je vous la mets juste au dessus de moi, ici ou ici...
Ca doit être ici d'ailleurs...
Et on avait, avec Philippe Roche, enlevé comme ça des tiges avec un aimant.
Bon, on va faire face par face, ça me paraît mieux. Ca, on voit que c'est un bloc solidaire, mais quand même, je me méfie...
de ce qu'ils ont fait, là, les dessins avec...
avec la toile d'araignée, ça pourrait être aussi pour déguiser ou pour cacher une partie complètement amovible.
Là en l'occurrence, je pense pas du tout...
Ca, c'est juste le bord de cet élément là, et ça...
ça m'a pas l'air amovible. Je la lève un petit peu parce que j'aimerais pas...
en appuyant, bloquer quelque chose.
OK, donc là, sur sa face gauche...
on a à peu près les mêmes représentations.
Ca, ça fait partie de cette planche, ces points là, celles-ci de celle là...
et ça ici. Alors, ici on a un axe...
qui bouge, et qui est clairement levier d'ici.
Je sais pas si vous voyez bien ici, que ça se lève légèrement, très légèrement, quand j'appuie, juste là.
Donc j'imagine qu'on a la même chose de l'autre côté, OK.
Donc ça, soit c'est un axe de levier, soit c'est au contraire quelque chose qui bloque et qu'il faudrait essayer d'enlever.
Ce qui est possible. Je ne sais pas, en fait, si ce qu'on voit là, le noir, c'est solidaire de là.
Je suis allé un petit peu vite aujourd'hui sur les explications, et vous savez...
la première phase...
sur les boîtes, c'est comme dans les Escape Games, c'est de faire une phase d'exploration, de voir qu'est ce qui bouge, qu'est ce qui bouge pas...
quelles sont les actions possibles qu'on a à faire dessus.
Et sachant que c'est une difficulté extrême, forcément, je me méfie.
Elle est ouf cette boîte parce que...
elle a l'air de rien. Tu ne te dis pas, vraiment, tu te dis pas en voyant ça, "ça va être une difficulté extrême".
Et la difficulté je la vois direct, avec le fait que rien ne bouge nulle part.
Tiens, j'ai vraiment juste accès à...
Ah oui, la barre elle est entière, elle est vraiment solidaire.
Tu as la barre, comme ça, qui traverse de part en part, et qui est clairement rattaché à ça, et quand je dis "j'ai accès" c'est...
J'arrive à y toucher avec la pulpe de mon doigt en poussant bien fort.
L'autre chose que j'ai réussi à faire, donc là en appuyant ça fait rien, et si on appuie vraiment ici, par contre, on voit que...
ça s'ouvre. Donc il faut que j'arrive à comprendre...
qu'est ce qui bloque le système, pour peut-être partir du blocage, pour aller ensuite vers le déblocage.
Là je suis pas juste comme dans Rain Man.
Je suis en train de voir, comme avec le cadenas qu'on a fait au tout début du mois d'août, le cadenas 64 qui était...
très, très dur, voir s'il n'y a pas une bille ou quelque chose qui bouge à l'intérieur.
Je me dis, en fait, s on n'a pas de mouvement...
mécanique, en touchant, peut-être qu'il y a quelque chose sur une rotation, quelque chose comme ça qui...
Non, ça c'est moi. Putain, je me suis auto-prank !
Vous savez, c'est comme dans les vidéos de fantômes en fait,
où il y a quelqu'un qui marche et qui fait bouger quelque chose, et puis son pote dit "Y'a eu un fantôme !" "Bah non, c'est moi en fait".
Bah là, forcément, ça retombe un peu plus...
Qu'est-ce qui l'empêche d'ouvrir ?
J'arrive pas à comprendre si ce qui l'empêche c'est justement ce qui est ici, de part en part du trou...
ou si c'est plus par là devant. Ils pensaient que là, ça le retiendrait...
Parce que dans ces cas là, ça ne serait pas du tout un levier, et si ça se trouve elle... Eh, mais non !
Je raconte de la merde, je dis n'importe quoi ! En fait, là on voit deux petits picots de bois, qui rentrent directement en fait dans les trous...
Donc, on voit en même temps qu'ils sont solidaires, on peut pas...
Je pourrai pas enlever le couvercle autrement qu'en ouvrant la boîte comme ça.
C'est un bon indice. Et en parlant d'indice, l'araignée donne peut-être un indice en fait.
Sinon pourquoi faire une araignée et faire toute une toile comme ça ? Donc l'araignée, elle regarde dans cette direction-là.
Du moins j'ai l'impression... En fait la forme de ses pattes tend à me faire penser qu'elle regarde précisément ici.
Juste là.
Ca donne envie d'appuyer quand même !
Elle est fort, fort jolie cette boîte, mais je sens qu'elle va vite me rendre dingue !
En plus y'a un truc qui m'énerve depuis le départ, j'arrive pas à comprendre pourquoi...
il y a cette forme là ici.
Pourquoi ils n'ont pas coupé droit...
Peut-être juste pour laisser une marge de sécurité à la découpe pour ça... Ah putain ça me rend dingue !
En fait, les casse-têtes, y'a jamais rien qui est fait au hasard, tout a un sens. Mais il ne faut pas voir du sens...
des fois partout dans la résolution. Ca peut être juste du sens...
comme là, je me dis, "ça doit être par rapport à la fabrication" en fait.
Peut-être ! J'en sais rien...
Parce que ça quand ça s'ouvrira, ça ira à l'intérieur ici, donc ils auraient pu exploiter ce volume là en fait...
Bon, il y a deux choses qui m'embêtent.
Ca fait un petit moment, là, quand même, que je suis dessus. En fait, ce que j'essaye de faire...
c'est de visualiser la boîte en 3D dans ma tête, comme on a déjà pu le faire sur d'autres casse-têtes...
Vous avez vu, je suis en mode sérieux là, je suis en mode "vraiment, ça va pas".
Parce que je veux...
j'arrive rien à voir par l'extérieur, donc il faut comprendre comment marche l'intérieur. Il y a deux trucs qui m'embêtent sur cette boite. Il y a ça...
Il n'y a aucune raison pour qu'il y ait une partie métallique ici,
donc, pour moi, métal = aimant,
et il y a ce petit truc noir. Et en fait depuis tout à l'heure je me dis "à quoi ça sert ?"
si ce n'est pas pour retenir vers l'avant.
Je pense que c'est pas ici que c'est bloqué, que c'est ici que ça...
qu'on n'arrive pas.
Et du coup c'est quand même...
beaucoup d'éléments qui se retrouverait devant, et je trouve que ma théorie elle marche. On a un bout de métal ici...
et pour moi, métal, c'est aimant, et ça...
En fait, si on regarde partout, à chaque fois qu'on avait un truc noir sur cette boîte, un élément foncé,
c'est un élément d'une autre planche. Donc, ils ont été obligés d'évider pour mettre quelque chose ici en supplément.
Dans ma tête, j'imagine...
que ce petit bout de bois, là,
c'est une espèce de crochet, comme ça, comme un demi U on va dire, ou un trois quarts de U, un peu comme un hameçon...
et qu'à l'intérieur il y ait une tige qui passe, soit dans ce sens-là, hameçon et tige,
soit au contraire c'est lui qui fait la tige, et il y a un endroit qui hameçonne  ça et qui fait que...
au moment de lever, en fait, on ne peut pas parce qu'il y a quelque chose qui bloque. Vous voyez un peu l'idée quoi ?
Donc j'ai une idée pour le débloquer,
mais si c'est ça,
si la réponse c'est ça, c'est bâtard. En en temps normal, il y a un truc qu'on ne peut pas faire avec les casse-têtes, c'est forcer.
Je dis bien "en temps normal" parce que là, y'a des des papiers où il y a juste marqué "il suffit d'appuyer" etc.
Là il n'y avait pas d'indication du tout.
Aucune, zéro indication. Donc soit ils n'en ont pas mises, soit c'est qu'on a le droit de faire à peu près tout ce qu'on veut avec.
Je me dis, si ça se trouve c'est une action mécanique comme ça.
Putain j'y ai cru !
J'ai cru, l'espace d'un instant, j'y ai cru !
Si, on entend... on entend le métal en plus !
Là j'entends clairement que c'est pas du bois, là !
Dans la retenue ça fait métallique. Vous entendez ?
Une petite... Un petit arrière son de métal !
En fait, je me dis, si on arrive à débloquer un peu...
C'était ça. C'était tellement ça ! [Musique dramatique]
Ah putain, je viens de tout comprendre. Excusez-moi, je viens de craquer la boîte d'Einstein. On doit se checker du coup.
Ca c'est la preuve, par Einstein, qu'à chaque fois qu'on veut faire un check à quelqu'un on se prend un vent.
OK, mortel, mais trop malin, beaucoup trop malin en fait comme boîte.
Je l'ai eu. Alors pas complètement par hasard, parce que ce que j'avais imaginé, c'est vraiment...
en grande partie ce qu'il y a dedans,
mais je pense qu'il y a une petite part de hasard après sur la fin. Alors ce que je pensais être un U...
bon c'est pas un U, c'est un gros bloc tout seul...
perforé d'un trou. Par contre, j'avais raison sur le principe que c'est une pièce qui était bien rajoutée à ici, d'où ce truc noir...
Le bout de métal, qui me faisait penser à un aimant,
c'est clairement pas du tout un aimant.
On va pas se mentir, c'est pas un aimant... Ah voilà, il vient de se remettre.
Mais par contre, il y avait bien une tige...
qui passait dans ce trou pour l'empêcher d'en sortir. Ce qui fait que là, j'ai remis la tige,
et à l'inverse, on ne peut pas fermer parce que la tige, elle bloque. et on entend ce que j'entendais tout à l'heure, le bruit de métal !
Et du coup, pour enlever le métal, il doit être lui retenu par un aimant...
Alors c'est quand j'ai tapé dans l'autre sens ?
Ah c'est ça OK. Pour enlever le métal, il faut, ça c'est vraiment salaud de leur part, il faut donner un coup sec...
sur la table ou dans la main, j'en sais rien, pour libérer la tige...
que vous voyez ici,
et qui elle, je pense, au bout de ce côté là, est retenue par un aimant. J'ai pas un bout de métal, moi, pour tester ?
Attends, je vais chercher...
Je vais chercher un petit bout de métal de la Pandora Box.
[Musique dramatique]
Je vais prendre un aimant de la Pandora Box pour aller voir s'il y a bien un aimant ici.
Ca c'est bien une tige métallique...
Ah, d'ailleurs, du coup la direction...
Ca c'est peut-être dans ma tête, mais je me dis que la direction de l'araignée, elle va bien dans le sens où il faut taper.
Et oui, voilà. Je vais le refaire pour que vous puissiez bien le voir.
Là, en fait, avec l'aimant, j'ai saisi par l'intérieur la petite tige métallique,
et je la remmène  ici,
et donc, il y a bien un aimant au bout qui la retient. Mais pas un aimant très puissant, puisque je peux même faire des allers-retours...
Ce qui explique pourquoi, en donnant un petit coup, après ça repart. Ah oui, là on le sent bien l'aimant !
C'est très malin, c'est très ingénieux, mais c'est doublement ingénieux de leur part,
dans le sens où, les habitués des casse-têtes, en fait, nous on sait qu'il faut pas taper !
Extrêmement astucieux ! Putain si vous mettez ça dans les mains de quelqu'un qui a l'habitude...
de faire des des casse-têtes, je pense que jamais il n'osera taper...
En fait j'ai osé, parce qu'à un moment donné, il fallait bien aller sur une piste...
Mais en temps normal, on ne violente pas les casse-têtes, ce n'est pas la méthode de résolution. Ce qui fait que pour le refermer, il suffit de faire ça...
et ça.
J'ai kiffé cette boîte. La Einstein Box, ou la Spider Box, je vous mets le lien en description pour ceux que ça intéresse.
Elle est... Du coup, c'est une boîte avec une seule action pour la résoudre, et vous savez,
souvent, les casse-têtes qui n'ont qu'une marge de manœuvre,
je vous en avais parlé dans une dernière vidéo, ce sont les casse-têtes les plus compliqués à résoudre parce que...
on ne peut pas faire un step by step, en fait, il faut tout de suite trouver la bonne idée de résolution.
J'aime bien. Elle part dans mes boîtes préférées, avec la Pandora Box du coup, je vais les ranger ensemble. beaucoup trop cool
Beaucoup trop cool !
J'aime bien les boîtes. Les boites, ça fait partie en fait de mes casse-têtes préférés au final.
Mais après, c'est pas toujours...
les plus longs à résoudre, ou en tout cas...
les plus saisissants, à part les step by step, mais ça c'est très, très cool.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo ! Pensez à la liker, quand même,
si elle vous a plus, ça c'est cool, ou à vous abonner à la chaîne si ce n'est pas encore fait.
Je vous mets autour de moi quelques anciens casse-têtes,
le prochain sera mercredi prochain,
à 6 heures, et on sera deux ce coup-ci.
Et on fera deux casse-têtes. Eh oui, c'est fou mais il faut qu'on en profite !
Et en parlant de profiter, cette transition est incroyable,
n'oubliez pas qu'il y a le spectacle à l'Olympia le 22 septembre,
il ne reste plus beaucoup de places, il est temps de réserver, vous avez le lien dans la description,
et ça part ensuite, ce spectacle là, en tournée dans plus de 40 villes, vous avez les dates sur mon site, fabienolicard.fr.
A très bientôt, ciao !